meanwhile federal records reveal
congresswoman elon omar's husband
got more than 600 thousand dollars in
coronavirus relief money
for his political consulting firm on top
of the millions that his company
received from her
election campaign charles payne has
hosted making money on the fox business
network he joins us now
charles you'll have to explain this one
to me we'll put it up on the screen this
is the e
street group receiving in total
thirty 634 thousand nine hundred dollars
in funds ppp a hundred and thirty four
thousand of that disaster loans five
hundred thousand dollars
why uh you know
the the the big knock against the whole
uh the whole ppp
program was that uh you know one percent
of the recipients got 25
of the money and often they were very
well connected very rich people
or organizations and there's no doubt
that's true
there was a sort of sense of urgency
though to get the money out hoping that
if there were flaws at least it would
help the most under
you know the most the ones who were in
the most dire need of the cash
and a lot of it did you know they're
going to have another chance to do it
again and probably more be more
tailored or more specific but this just
kind of speaks to
sort of these insiders who who have the
ability to
to to take advantage of these sort of
things all the time and then of course
you know this particular group of people
it's it's so
so bad in the sense that sanjay they're
always knocking
everything right they knocked everything
that president trump did they always
knock america
they always talk about how unfair
everything is and here they are feeding
out the trough
when other people really needed this
money more desperately because they knew
how to get it
so they did
uh that firm was also paid more than two
million dollars since the start of the
year charles
uh from omar's campaign for digital
advertising
fundraising consulting website
production
she announced last month i should
mention in november that her campaign
was terminating its contract
with that firm because of all the
scrutiny that she was receiving over
those payments
yeah but no money is going to be
returned i mean listen services were
delivered but this is something people
were talking about this cozy
relationship long before november she
had a chance to take care of it then she
did not it was too much money
millions of dollars it was too much to
ignore they took it they'll take a
little bit of scrutiny
it won't be a lot the media will not
focus on it it will go away
but the bottom line is america's
distrust and the public
america's distrust in media this is why
both are free fall